[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
righto the lads just keep coming and
today is no different as we have one of
the most all-time requested lads on the
podcast throughout his career he's been
one of the most recognizable figures
with his facial hair and hairstyles and
he was always one of the fans favorite
playing for manoa too taranaki the
hurricanes and of course the mighty all
blacks he also spent some time in japan
before heading over to france where he
became a larashow legend he achieved all
that while always being an absolute lad
who loved his beer and a good time it is
the great man himself jason eaton
welcome mate hello nintendo thanks mate
mate you are looking great facial hair
as good as always
oh thank you thank you uh you know i i i
was just thinking about this morning
watching the um
all blacks play the usa i was watching
that and looking at all the headers they
outside
look at that that's like you know i did
that like 15 years ago and now i'll
mullita i wouldn't do it if everyone
else is saying i didn't win no i was
doing it
you did it to me different yeah i do it
to be different not to fall in the crowd
but
yeah yeah i had um lem squire on last
week and he he sort of felt like he was
a little bit ahead of his time as well
but i might you were five plus years
ahead of him so you really started the
trend
you know it was a shocking one and then
uh yeah then then you've got a you know
my flat my andrew keith thor told me to
when i got injured there well when he
got injured by sort of shoulder you know
so i didn't shave or cut my hair until i
played again so i was like oh i'll do
that too and
that was when i first screw up the big
beard and long hair and stuff so
yeah i don't know what excuses now
and do you love it do you still love
having your big beard
uh well i've always said this like i i
do like growing a bed because i hatch
over and i i i feel like it's a real
time waster and a bit of a drago like um
it's so much easier to have
um or not to shave it's a lot easier to
do that than than worry about everything
and going to you know barb every two
weeks like some some guys do um oh i
think i i enjoy the bed i think i suit
it so
it comes and goes you know i tend to
grow up for a year and then chop it off
and
go start again
you've got so much more time for other
things now that you don't have to shave
exactly well you think that's a few
minutes
each well depends how often you shave i
guess i don't need to show you when i'm
on a building site
does it ever get itchy for you how do
you get past that phase because that's
where i always get stuck i let it grow
until it gets itchy which is
roughly about three weeks that's a very
common question around the bed um you
know i get actually from week
two to week three four um
but then once you pass that it's fine it
sort of grows on your hair a bit like
pubes i guess you know
it's just sort of
you gotta curl it killer in your face
but i mean there's it becomes like soft
and and not so scratchy after a while
once so long enough but i guess it's
just having that just discipline to get
through
and what's your routine with it do you
have to clean it or like how often would
you clean it do you use any oils or
anything
oh
yeah i guess now like i always you wash
my hair and when i do that i wash my
beard and
i've run a conditioner through it as
well yeah um
and i've actually like previously
i never oiled um
i've recent notes or like the last year
or two i've actually got the oils on to
it and more just for the skin underneath
that you don't really get to clean the
skin and
um
you're just trying to and it smells a
bit nicer too it always helps that is
that is good insight to start the
podcast on growing facial hair oh
great start it's pretty easy just don't
show
it'll get there not everyone gets that
growth like you though
anyway
so most people will think that you're
retired but mate
rumor tells me you were running around
club rugby last season talk me through
this
how did i get involved there so i think
coming out of the first very first
lockdown in 2020 i was
i felt like i was i was being a bit more
of a too much of a hermit you know just
staying at home and not really getting
out involved with people and
sort of had a
career change as well and
i thought a good way to connecting with
people was get back into club rugby so
good friend of mine michael barnes um
you know i was involved with the old
boys university club here in wellington
and
i reached out to him and said i'm out
keen to come along and sort of
you know just help out and keep an eye
on the line out sort of thing of the
senior team and
um and basically connect with people and
you know get a few connections going and
yeah and that sort of thing and then um
i think i at that stage i had signed up
to play the uh
was it the parliamentarian team or so i
was playing for the centurions against
parliamentarian the one that um actually
bloomfield
yeah so
i had that game coming up and then i
turned up to my first training to you
know look at the
overused sort of seniors and that and um
the reserve coach
paul swift yells out to me and you know
says g'day and goes uh
you got that game in a couple of weeks
ago you know um
the parliamentarian game i think you
need to run before that oh what do you
reckon we were short this weekend she
was like oh actually you got a good
point i wouldn't mind dusting off the
cobwebs
um so i said yeah fair enough or you
know come along and
um
i just got about 20 minutes that first
game and then played that
parliamentarian game and then kept
turning up to trainings and
you know same old story with club footy
these days everyone's short and
keep saying i had chances again this
week i was like oh yeah no i can't i've
got nothing else on and
next thing you know i'm playing pretty
much every game
but absolutely loved it
you know especially playing for like the
reserve team was
you know the level that i was
comfortable with playing all the guys
here were there for the right reasons
and you know there for a bit of social
time and and yeah i love playing footy
and competing and that so
suited me down to a t and
um and then
actually i think i won my first final
actually of my career with the reserve
side in 2020.
i was playing off the fifth fifth place
but it was a final nonetheless
but he'll count
well i reckon that some of the boys are
still partying a year on actually for
that um
so it sort of sets its own of why i was
involved but um again 2021 i i again
reached out to them and said oh oh they
reached out to me this year and sort of
said you know you can come along and
i'll say yeah i'm keen to help out that
less this plane and
um sort of more of the coaching side i
think the for the reserve side and
sort of helped out when i could i was a
bit busy this year so
um i did don the boots maybe two or
three times um
and enjoyed it uh
yeah i sort of with the reserve side i
sort of had a couple of rules for them
though if i was playing i said look
um
you know if there's something else
that's fit they can play they play ahead
of me i don't want to take anyone else's
spot and
the second rule was i don't want to play
80 minutes
i'm comfortable coming off the bench
which was awesome
um which i think suited them as well and
uh yeah we had a great time i enjoyed it
um
yeah i don't know when i'll keep taking
up we'll see what happens you know come
whenever the season starts next year
march or something
am i getting you food again
that's so awesome so so your body's
obviously good like you you've had a
massive career and your body's still
sweet to be able to play rugby at that
level uh
i mean the body's not what it was you
know 20 years ago or whatever it was um
but i've seen a decent enough neck to
jog around and
you know i'm pretty sore after a game
even it was 20 minutes or so like it's
pretty pretty tiring and
um obviously you don't have the training
load behind me either like leading into
it
especially with you just rock up no
training
into the game um
but you know i mean i've
i was pretty lucky i mean i had a couple
of big injuries in that but uh no
long-term effects and
um you know i've managed to stay
reasonably fit post-rugby i haven't
blown out like some
others um i was really conscious of that
actually when i come towards the end of
my career to
try and change my habits um
around 18 and
and obviously you know trying to keep
fit but without actually doing too much
fitness if that makes sense and i was
never
keen on on the gym during my career i
need to kind of really went in the gym
because it was part of our job not
because i enjoyed it yeah
same with running i i've never enjoyed
running so
i since then i've sort of taken up a bit
of cycling and
um
but it's getting a bit hard with um you
know with my job at the minute i don't
really have too much time to do the
cycling and stuff but it kept pretty fit
on on the job site so
i've been pretty lucky i guess in that
regard so how did your rugby career
finish because i read somewhere that it
was a head not but
um how true is that one uh you know
that's it's commonly um
most people in new zealand think that i
retire because of um concussions um i
think there was an article published
at some stage saying i retired because
of hed knocks um
it's sort of coincided with one another
i was always going to retire that that
season
um so i sort of decided that i think
it's about january when i actually
decided and announced it and then
maybe february or march you know
actually i think it was late march i
i got a head knock that rock meant quite
a bit soon
um you know the season's only a couple
of months later
when it was when it was finished so
you know i didn't really come back from
from that head knock um in time to play
the last game or anything so
sort of looks like i've retired because
of the head knock but i was always
going to be so
um
yeah no no long-term effects from the
concussion but um i'll tell you it's one
that's probably the scariest injury i
actually received i guess um
you know a lot of other guys out there
have
a lot of necky guys especially that have
retired early because of it
um
you know obviously i was fortunate that
those guys had gone through it before
and
um i was quite aware of
i'll see the dangers of that so i was
obviously when i decided to retire to it
wasn't no no rush to get back um
i mean i was keen to play that one last
game sort of thing and have a bit of a
send off but
i wasn't going to risk anything for that
and you went straight into coaching with
lara show at the time was that right uh
yeah i mean on paper i guess yeah i did
um
yeah there's a bit of a story there um
your french rugby is quite funny um
yeah i think it's the last game
of the season i was playing
um
well as a player that uh there's a bit
of an argument that last very nice game
between the head coach and the other
coaches and stuff and
the thing we play that game and then
well season's finished
i think it got to a point where the head
coaches like or either
to the clubs or that you get rid of the
other clubs are wrong leaving and
so the head coach left he still had a
couple of years on his contract so he
sort of quit out of nowhere and
um
and i always plan to stay on in france
for a for a while and
take it easy and try and transition a
little bit easier out of rugby and
i see a little bit of europe as well and
and obviously you know set up things
with my partner before she moved
from france to new zealand and
um so obviously the coach quit and then
the club were like well we don't really
have a coach and
like you just stay around and stay
alongside the boys and
help transition
them from last season to the next one
and
so they had a contract
it's a well i think the role was like as
a transition guy or something like that
i don't even know what the word was but
i was like well
if i'm going to be involved i want to
actually you know be hands-on
so they're now signing a
a coaching contract um so it's just an
assistant coach really i mean they they
had the um
the old coaches sort of stepped up as
head coach and that sort of stuff and
which was pretty very challenging um
it definitely helped my french actually
because i all french coaches and that so
i she for once had to speak french full
time and
how the
other side sort of works and
obviously the french side is very
challenging like um
yeah coming up with good ideas what you
think are good ideas and just getting
the
nut that's not the way we do things
just getting shut down and
sort of like oh what am i doing here you
know like
sort of wasting my time so it got to a
point where actually
i did actually go on holiday um during
one of our breaks
um
and then sort of got told
pretty much if you don't want to come
back you don't have to so i was like
sweet i wish i booked a long holiday now
but uh
but i mean i was only i was going to
stay until you know sort of christmas
time so this is you know early november
so
um well that sort of stage i checked out
anyway and
um
there you know piranha jonathan gibbs
who who's doing the waikato season
and then coming over so you sort of
arrived as as i left and
um
yeah so that was a bit of an eye-opener
into the coaching and
managerial side of things did did you
enjoy it
ah
it was it was challenging obviously
going from
straight from playing into the same
environment as a coach
um i sort of didn't really know where i
sat
yeah and the scheme of things i don't
know where my sort of allegiances sort
of lay or you know who to sit with and
um it was kind of it was quite confusing
time and obviously i did sort of
transition role
by coach and
trying to work out actually where i fit
you know like um
it was quite challenging but um
yeah you know
as a player like um i spoke to a lot of
guys that were keen for me to be a coach
um but i i never really had aspirations
for it um
i always wanted to
when i finished playing i want to have a
separation from playing
if i got involved in coaching i wanted
to straight away i sort of
i saw it as sort of
you know you're sort of chasing the same
rugby players dream and
yeah by that stage i i'd had enough of
uh living overseas and going where the
work was
um you know i was keen to come home and
spend time with my son wellington and
um
you know and and try and set up my life
outside of rugby away from rugby and
then
you know coaching did come along
or it was something i was interested in
it would come along on the side of
whatever i'd done
um which is
still where i'm not still not there um i
guess with always university they're
pretty open to me just
helping out when i can which you know
might be
you know one train and a month or
a couple of games here or there and that
i know i think i'm pretty happy with
that but yeah which is which i'm pretty
fortunate to have
um and then maybe in the future who
knows but um for now you're like
yeah i see obviously coaching is you've
got to go with the workers and yeah
there's actually not a lot of jobs out
there that are
in the coaching side of things that you
can do full time and get paid decent
coin as well it's it's
it's quite a challenge
how hard was it to set up your life
outside of rugby you mentioned coming
back to new zealand and setting up your
life first so how has that been uh yeah
it's a huge challenge um
i mean everyone's got a different story
about it um
you know i think that the best thing i
that i
sort of thought about leading into it
was i knew that
it was going to be tough yeah
so my expectation was it's going to be
tough and challenging and all that sort
of stuff so
there was no
real big surprises around it um
so that's why i sort of planned to stay
in europe for
you know six months or so and
sort of have a bit of a break and a
holiday and
sort of ease into it and then
sort of had different focuses which was
part of my transition i guess was moving
back to new zealand was
you know first times trying to
get um
get back into my son's life more
regularly and
obviously transition my partner who's
french into new zealand way of life and
that sort of stuff and i sort of had all
these other focuses
more than on myself um
and then
it's probably about six months i was
into
on back in new zealand and just sort of
started kicking in like
you know i've actually got to sort
myself out and
you know get back out involved and
things and actually find a job which
i guess the hardest thing around that
for me was i've
never really known what i wanted to do
or still don't
um
so when you start to look for a job it's
like oh where do i start looking so when
i was
i was looking every day at um
all the job listings and that and
applying for like stock take jobs and
stuff just to get me out of the house
and yeah i mean i never i didn't end up
doing anything like that but um
i guess that was the biggest challenge
for me was
um
just and i still was you know trying to
sort out what
what it is i actually want to do
um
yeah
it's a good question i still don't know
what i want to do so how did building
come into it because now you're you are
working on a building site doing an
apprenticeship right oh there's this
yeah that's the one um yeah i guess so
uh within that first six months i ran
into i was on a stag do for um a mate of
mine rob hamilton's they do and
um
one of his or our mates as well was on
his james annabelle who
owns a uh honey company and he sort of
mentioned that i could i could have a
role for him selling honey which
which i thought um
you know sales was a really good
role to be in from a rugby background
obviously using the connections and
the the persona of a regular player
helps with the sales so
i stuck into that for about nine months
and then it sort of come to an end
um
you know both sort of ends you know the
company and myself sort of
parted ways by the end and and then that
that led into
the first lockdown and
of of covert in 2020 and
you know sort of that whole time was a
big time for a reflection i guess and
and try and
sort out actually what i wanted to do
and
i'll see you know six weeks you live in
the home and
um it's just me and me and my partner
and actually
her mother was actually over visiting
for a month that turned into three
months so
and it's been a bit of a time to
reflect on things and
you know one of those things was you
know sales
yeah i didn't feel it's set with me my
personality that well like um
yeah i'm pretty laid back and then i i
don't really like forcing people to
push in the case for people to buy honey
or whatever it is that's sort of not in
my nature so
um
it's probably not suited for me
uh so i sort of you know sat there going
what am i interested in like most rugby
players are sort of interested in
property and that so
i started researching a few things and
quite a few jobs out there and your
property management and
you know obviously
property development and all that sort
of stuff is something i'm interested in
um
and then everyone i spoke to is like
yeah it's awesome but if you want to do
that you sort of got to know what you're
doing first
and
suggest that i start from the bottom
also i don't mind doing that so
um
so i'll do my apprenticeship so i
researched around and found a good good
company in wellington and
that's uh it's been about a year or so
now maybe just over a year since i first
started with them and
getting stuck into the apprenticeship
which is
it's been awesome i've really enjoyed it
um
coming from the sales job to this one i
was a bit more physicality which yeah
obviously sits well with the background
of a rugby player and
um you know being hands-on and
obviously building creating things is
you know sits well with me and
um i thought i enjoyed it i'll see these
days like any job or you absolutely hate
like it's been a spin a day on the
shovel
it's not that nice after nine hours but
um on the whole yeah i find that i'm
really enjoying it and
yeah i'm pretty pretty happy of where
we are of decisions i've made you know
sort of in this career path and
um i'm saying that's all i mean i don't
know what i'm going to be doing in five
years or so but uh for the moment i'm
really happy and
and always put it i always sort of
said this about it it's like well if i
don't like building i'm still
learning you know really good life
skills and
things that are handy
know i'll be able to fix things a bit
more and you know if that's the worst
thing that comes out of this then yeah
it's a win so 100
that's uh that's that's been my sort of
theme on it does your height come in
handy on the building site or is that a
bit of a negative uh both
both so no letters required where do i
start negatives negatives are
negatives i hit my head a lot
you know scaffolding scaffolding's
designed to be you know this this high
and
you know so it's about this high so i'm
hitting my head all the time and
things like that or um
i'll see like what's another example
like i was found myself one day on a
roof trying to like
you know now like joyce down blow my
feet and just struggled like just to get
down that low and obviously a couple of
bad knees as well doesn't help
but you're stuck up there so you just
sort of
sort of do what you can do and then i
look around these other little little
fellas that you know non-rugby guys are
just scampering up and down the
of the roof and you know spinning over
and just all these and taking the piss
out of me but then i was like well you
know give me doing something else you
want to you need to go get a letter and
you're going to be able to reach it so
i stick to your strengths that's it
oh it's good stuff it's awesome to hear
how that that transition's gone and uh
good to hear that you're going well and
enjoying that building side of things
but anyway we need to get back to the
start for the jason eden story what was
what was growing up like for you
uh
you know
why i say it's pretty typical but i
guess everyone can probably say that
pretty typical childhood
um grew up on a farm
uh in the middle of two
near pahoangana there um so i was the
third third child two older brothers
um and a bit of a rugby family so
i would we're out playing sports
now every waking moment pretty much well
that was my plan anyway try and
keep keep my older brothers happy as
much as you can playing sports so they'd
come out and play as long as you can you
know when you get i've been older sort
of
you know maybe maybe get out a bit
easier in the cricket so they get a turn
and
so they stay out there a bit longer so
you keep playing
you know it's sort of balancing act um i
don't think they'd like to hear that but
you know i just want to be out there all
day
you know playing rugby and crooked and
everything else that that came up was
growing on growing up growing up on a
farm
um
yeah so i mean i i got stuck into rugby
from
well the story that my mum told me was
that uh i've seen two other brothers so
when they were playing i
i just joined in and
kept up with them so when i was three i
think it was
i started playing
um
so
you know it wasn't hurting anyone or
wasn't getting hurt so that's all you
can go away
so i
started pretty young and played every
year were you tall uh yeah i was taught
i mean
uh
you know i've always been pretty tall
obviously there's that stage during
you know around puberty and that where
people shot up at different stages and
stuff and
but apart from that was always sort of
you know back row the photos and
that sort of things um
yeah so i've always had a bit of height
a bit of size
and we always a lock like through your
age grades
no no i
i probably my first actual full season
as a lock would have been when i was 15
i reckon oh yeah
um
growing up um
i was always the first five actually
i was young
my oldest brother brett he was a half
back so
yeah he was he was very um keen on
working on his pass
and
being the first five was perfect because
i was catch him and you know i worked on
my kicking and left some stuff and
um size first five up until
probably about intermediate age and then
it sort of got moved to this you know
second five and
a little bit of fallback at high school
and that
and then had one season at blindside i
think that 14 at full form
um once obviously the height she
you know actually came about like proper
height and
going oh that's where the future's going
to be so
which was was just quite challenging
like um
it took me a number of years to actually
get put my head in the right places so
you know i still thought i was back even
though i was in a different number on my
back
but um
[Music]
sort of at school you know i wasn't
always the best player
um
but uh
yeah it turned out okay at the end how
tall were you at school like when you
because you went to palmy boys right
were you first
fifteen last year was 15 and sort of
towards the end of my sixth form yeah
it's um
it was a bit of a funny old story at
school i um
back then um in the middle too sort of
secondary schools era was the trials for
men or two secret schools was the party
boys first of doing against the best of
the rest
so in my sixth form here i was in the
second fifteen so i was playing against
the first of them
was um
with the other like hayden hazlett from
um the the second 15
and then uh where she got picked in the
manor two signature schools both of us
playing against the first team so it's
like oh how does this work you know like
um
and then uh then the next year same
thing happened but i'm i was in the
fifth scene this year and
it was me and lloyd budd were the main
locks for the first of dean and we
trialled
against the best of the rest and now
coaches were like oh you guys will get
an easy
we'll give the other guys a bit of a run
um
which was i think it was again i think
it was again hayden hayden and
ed pierce i think was the other two
locks he got a run and
so they played us for the first quarter
and then played the other guys
i think the other guys got in and we
didn't
and it's just like what do you do
so yeah the high school's a bit of a
funny old one but um yeah i
always look back and i think high school
ramp is probably the most
intense
passionate rugby i've ever played in
like i think it's just an age thing
where you know you think you're
better than you are and yeah it's the be
all on the end all like playing firstly
in rugby and
obviously such traditional games you
know playing for the pulse and banner or
you guys name your boys or nappy men's
as they'll say and
um or playing against new employees at
the gully ground there in new plymouth
and
having the whole school there doing the
hacker on the on the side yeah it is
really special and
um
yeah at the time you think you've made
it
um
and yeah it's probably the most nervous
i actually got before rugby games was
probably back then
um
yes it's very very intense so i guess
you might get that a bit of nelson yeah
it was the same as it yeah 100 i i'm the
same as you i used to get probably more
nervous for those games than any other
game i remember
first game like at jade stadium or and
things like that just so nervous about
the
the big game oh you're playing a change
jesus
flash school mate it's a good time
it's no gully though is it the galley
the galley's one of them no jelly no
that's one of a kind
so was all was rugby always like your
dream was it always to make it as a
professional
uh
no i guess at high school i i
growing up as a kid i was uh
mad on rugby like you know posters on
the wall like everything i watched every
game i could
you know he played in the morning ball
boyd food club rang b and all sorts of
things i was mad about it
you know i guess in my teenage years i
i sort of got a bit sick of it but still
loved playing so i you know i still
trained and played and that
um and then obviously through the high
school career i was
i mean i was keen on playing rugby but i
never thought oh this is
what i'm gonna do for a career or
anything like that i'll sort of i'll
just keep playing and
keep enjoying it i thought maybe it
might be a chance but
it wasn't a real big focus
so i left school and
i remember my mother's telling me to
find a job or go to uni or so i
don't know what i would do for work i
still don't but um so i went to uni and
followed everyone there and
joined the club
um field and yellows joined them and and
just absolutely loved playing club rugby
and
um they're in manila too
and then my second year i think i
got to
make them out on two side and this was
back in
uh what are you were you talking now
2002 div two at the time div two yeah so
another two playing second division
um
so you was getting always getting paid
at this stage but it was like 200 for a
win yeah
before tax what about a loss
no no money for a loss oh it's true only
if you won it's just yeah i think i
think we had a i think i signed a
contract it might have been like two
thousand dollars
for the season yeah and then two hundred
200 win bonus and then i might have gone
to 400 dollars for or 200 for a playoff
and
an extra 200 for a one or something like
that i don't something like that anyway
um
and which was awesome being a student
because you know i'd have no money all
year and one week all summer trying to
save up money to get through the year
and
come now two season i had no money so
i think i was borrowing off my flatmate
actually to pay the bills and
just waiting for my my kicks to come in
uh
go down to fitz and
buy tro bourbons and
away you go
but uh yeah i guess i i was probably in
that second
season for too i was like oh you know
things are going okay um
you know what
what what would it take to
be a professional rave player um
so obviously the next step was to
go from second division the first
division so um at the time i think my
mum and my club coach at the time bill
clark was also my mum's boss actually
intermediate
um
sort of put together a bit of a cv and
i don't even know whether it was like a
cd rom or something of highlights or
something i don't know
whether they did that or not back then
but i had no idea i was sort of
pretty oblivious to it um
i can on it but uh so they sent that out
into whoever they sent it to
and i think who came back i think north
harbour and taranaki came back sort of
said i would be interested
um so
taranaki is just up the road so it makes
sense to me so i went and signed
i think i had to go signing in front of
the
justice of the peace or something so i
think when i was working at the freezing
works here in field and i
had to go early to the court and field
him and sign it on some day and
so then yeah i moved up to taranaki and
um
and then played club rugby for stratford
um
you know made the uh the squad that year
in 2004
uh for the taranaki but didn't get a run
at all like they had some
sort of good players at stage playing
lock um
obviously a lot better than me at that
stage
um so they had uh paul tito was
obviously captain and risa robinson was
ella locke and
scott berman
um was also there and doing a good job
so i played bees the whole year which
yeah again looking back i actually love
that season i mean
i did throw my toys a little bit that i
wasn't getting an opportunity but i
think that was just me being young and
um
thinking i was a bit better than i was
yeah um
then yeah i was 2005 had uh another club
season and then
i think bruce robinson actually moved on
i'm not too sure exactly where you went
but um
so there's a bit of a
bit of opportunity there and then i
think taranaki actually
played uh the british nourish lines
which was actually not been my first
game for taranaki actually
um
which i mean at the time i didn't really
realize how big a game it was really
looking back it was pretty massive first
game and
obviously there's a massive crowd at
euro stadium yeah
um and i'll see the whole touring things
back when
you know i'll see if i can tour and fill
full-out stadiums and all that sort of
stuff um the good old days the good old
days but uh it wasn't probably until
then
i mean even still then i was trying to
work during the club season doing odd
jobs
um
[Music]
you know i still struggling to think
whether i was
going to make that next step to
the hurricanes and then i don't know
what happened that year um
that uh a new zealand couple i think was
cool back then was um yeah
was a bit of a game changer really i
sort of got a crack the first game which
you know years later i heard um
andrew horwitz had a bit of a word that
saying he's
came to have
me in the lineup to throw to were you
good mates at this stage no i've never
met him until
i think this is just after his little
incident down in dunedin with his mates
yeah um and i didn't know who he was or
didn't even know the story and
people were joking about this
the seal shooter or something else i i
had no idea about what was going on
um
yeah i didn't know from barrack to be
honest he just wanted you on that line
out you just wanted to throw it to me i
guess um i guess this stage i was you
know like
probably 105 kilos or something and
two over two meters tall so
pretty easy to lift yeah
um
easy target i guess
um so i think he had a bit of a hand in
giving me that first game that's why
ketho and
um
yeah i think the rest is history after
that like i think
things went all right mate you must you
had a dramatic rise because that same
year was it the end of that year that
you got called into the all blacks as an
absolute bolter yep
that's right mate yeah um
yeah again there's this sort of stories
i hear like years later was um
well i didn't know at the time but uh
steve hansen come to look at chris masoe
one of our weeks
[Music]
i think we're preparing for auckland
it's a home game in new plymouth there
and
so steve came and have a look at masowi
and
you know sort of seen how he ticks and
give him a few pointers and stuff and
um as i found out later was neil barnes
was our coach then a ford's coach
and he's here sort of had a word to
steve about
about me and i had no idea but
um
he said oh yeah look at this kid he's
got something about him so i'll found
out later
so i mean during during the week he sort
of helped me a bit with the line outs
and a few other things a few pointers i
thought i was just been a good bargainer
and helped me out um
but then we played
auckland on the weekend and this year
2005 we had an absolute shock at
taranaki we um
we went we beat northland which everyone
beat northland so it wasn't saying much
we lost the around the game and then
this game against auckland we i don't
know what happened
whether it's steve being in town or
something like that or um
afternoon footy we just turned it on and
i just had one of these games out of the
bag like um
and one like 10 line out stole like two
or three from them and
topped the table tackle count and scored
a try and
just didn't put a foot wrong like just
one of these dream games and yeah from
what i know like that was the one game
that maybe you know go on in new york
which happened to be the one that was
you know steve was here watching and
um
yeah midnight i
was still weird weird sort of scenario
getting that
the first phone call from graham henry
and
was the first time i heard about the all
blacks was i um
at the time i was living in a stratfor
with
a few guys and
we used to play uh becky cricket on a
tent grass tennis court under on the
flood lights
um so me and
the two flat uh boy flatmates uh ross
williams and peritopia were out there
playing cricket
on the floodlights late at night and
then
my other flatmates um victoria
answered one of my phone and
comes out and goes oh jc is a phone call
for graham on the
on the phone i'm like what
i
don't dennis is like
jas yeah g'day graeme henry here
hi hi
piss off well what are you doing ringing
me like this this can't be you who is it
because that asks me as i i think you
had a good season i wanted you to keep
fit just in case
and then you know he sort of went on say
that there was um well it was back when
they had like
quarterfinals
we first bought in the quarterfinals
about about then and
so graham invited all the guys that went
playing in the quarterfinals down to
wellington for a camp
um
i showed up and i was just like what am
i doing here i'm like these are the guys
that i know from telly and that um
so there's a you know two-day camp a bit
of a training and stuff and
at the end they go right just because
you're here doesn't mean you're getting
on tour and
i was uh yeah okay yeah thanks for the
invite i went back to stratford and
yeah i didn't really tell anyone that i
was there
um
and i think that obviously the team name
he came out
um
must be coming up and then i think i
went and played golf
like the day before and then i think
taranaki were trying to organize like a
press conference just in case
yeah well that's what i was told just in
case and they couldn't get hold of me
because i was out playing golf
and then they i think they rang my mum
to try and find me
and i hadn't told her a thing and she
was just like then i had all these
miscalls from here as well okay what the
[ __ ] going on like what do you tell us
i was like wow
well i'm not going to make it but i'm
what he was so i'm not making a big deal
about it and then uh it's just the
biggest drama ever but
but then lo and behold yeah the team got
named next day and
um
yeah i was read out pretty early being
eaten obviously pretty early in the
alphabet so
um you know big shock um
you know when it went to the press
conference and that and then uh the
story is that
my mates all in stratford went out to
buy some kegs beer and there was no kegs
at all in stratfor
i had to buy um crates i think
so i think it was it was actually labor
weekend actually i think it was the
sunday of labor weekend so monday was um
obviously holiday so
the boys got stuck in
and did you did you feel comfortable
like doing all this media did you feel
comfortable being named an all black uh
no
to be honest nah i i wasn't comfortable
at all um
it was just so unexpected and out of the
blue
um
and i guess like
obviously i mean i played for metal too
and then i did like
interviews on on with the
local newspaper and
i don't think i did any real real
interviews with um
with taranaki apart from maybe the
newspaper as well there
that's that
so it wasn't really comfortable doing
that um yeah and obviously the nature of
coming out of nowhere and actually being
named was a
huge shock um
so i sort of felt
unreal sort of felt like it was
happening to someone else
um if that makes sense and obviously
then going into camp like
was very strange like i've been to
i'd only been overseas once and
there was the gold coast with my brother
and
so i didn't i didn't have any money i
didn't have a credit card i didn't have
a suitcase
i didn't even know what to pack for like
five weeks
um so it must have been strange for like
the like the manager and like the the
liaison people from the orbits like i
was writing them up just outlasting like
yeah random questions like you know what
how many
how many undies pairs of undies do i
need or like
like can you order this so something
like and then it was like labor day so i
couldn't like
organize credit cards because the banks
closed um
i was like oh this is nightmare so i
think i ordered a credit card but then
had to get like the chairman of new
zealand rugby to bring it over with them
to um
where were we in wales like the first
week and
um it was very strange very strange and
obviously like being in the environment
like
because i knew
it was only um andrew horror and chris
marceau the only other guys i actually
knew
in the in the whole squad um led into it
but um so that felt really strange like
almost like a feeling like i didn't
belong
yeah um
but in their environment i don't know
how long it would be going on beforehand
but
um
at that stage they were like they went
out of their way to welcome you into the
group
um
i mean you hear the stories of guys
especially in your position that
wouldn't
wouldn't welcome in the new guys and you
know treat them like [ __ ] or yeah it was
hierarchy and stuff but i guess at that
stage you know 2005 there was none of
that
um
you know i roomed with chris jack i
think the first week and
you know he went out his way to make
sure i
i was obviously getting across
everything game wise and
all the support i needed and obviously
had like lots of meetings for the new
guys and
you know you sort of get to know the ins
and outs of being an all black pretty
quickly and
you know there's a lot of support there
which which makes sense though looking
back it's like pretty awesome for
for likes myself going in there from
from where i'd come from and um
you know getting that support and it
makes sense to
you only the best out of players if you
should do that if it's an inclusive
environment
the old school sort of mentality you've
got in your stripes and yeah
and that that way so
appreciative of that
and what was the tour like it was a bit
of an eye opener um
so what happened we flew out
flew to cardiff
um
i think we arrived like the thursday
week before the test so we had about you
know nine days i think before the test
and
so hit the ground a couple of trainings
and then uh
obviously as i said earlier it's like my
first time traveling so first time
experiencing jet lag
i had no idea what was going on i was
you know
i think got to the saturday night they
gave us sunday off um so saturday night
i was lying on beard
falling asleep and about about seven
o'clock at night also
this is pretty good for my jelly so i'll
get up and just walk around the hotel
and
walked out of my hotel room and bumped
into a few guys and
oh what are you up to though i was just
going on the road for a beer and you
want to come along like
okay
so when i put my strides on and
went down to the i'll walk about there
and
turn up and there's just like a you know
one of these big chili bins like a meter
high full of coronas and
i'm like oh this [ __ ] this is a bad you
know part of my life is awesome
and i remember walking down there and
obviously this is andrew's
now he's just got back in the all blacks
from his
incident earlier in the year and he was
on a short leash so he goes online again
now for two beers and i'm going home and
i was like sweet it sounds good to me
well two beers came came and went and
you know friday jason going home
all right okay yep see you later mate
i'm freaking having a good time yeah
having a good night
so anyway fast forward to about
all right three o'clock or something i
come back to the hotel and there's a few
guys still in the bar and
having a few drinks and
um
didn't we get kicked out the hotel bar
so we end up by the lob you know by our
sort of team room and drinking a few
beers and
and someone came up with the idea
to go to the church
in london from cardiff i was like
well i don't know what's going on here
but uh i mean we're looking around the
room
looking around the guys on my all these
uh aaron major and leon macdonald from
the leadership group and dan carter
who's like the greatest player in the
world
then there's pity weepu and jimmy cowen
and myself
okay like
oh this is what all blacks do okay sweet
so i think
i remember the the actual decision to
actually go we're gonna write it
if we'll do like we were drinking
heinekens at the time so that there's
old obviously the label so if you drink
and stop in the label it's like in the
zone or something that's what it's
called or something yeah so right we
come around everyone just does a drink
and the majority get it in we're going
and i think i threw it i was like no
i don't think we should go so
i drank short or something like that
but then everyone else got it
so it's alright let's go
so someone ordered a cab 180 quid
get us from the from there from curt
cardiff to the church
but the funny thing is like we had like
management coming down to like go for a
run in the morning or come down to
breakfast and we're outside like i said
i don't know how someone would stop us
but anyway
jump in the cab or sort of in the cab
mode or whatever and partying and
singing and
get to the church and it's 10 a.m and no
church doesn't open to 12. so
it was so bizarre i mean i remember we
ended up
at one stage i mean enough and i mean i
don't think carter put this in this book
but
enough at subway or mcdonald's or
something and then sort of just waiting
for 12
and i remember seeing a hairdresser
sitting in a hairdresser watching dan
carter get his hair washed
um just killing time for the church
this is so weird but it must be like
what all blacks do
um
and then i think someone sort of
realized oh this is a bad idea so
they're like right that's my decision
again was but we didn't have the best
that it decided for us this time was
just like all right we can stay and have
an awesome time being absolute
you know wrecks tomorrow and
um or we can just make the best of a bad
situation so we end up training home and
sulking home and
it was an interesting trip home sitting
next to jimmy hood i think he'd been
seen home from um
brisbane earlier in the year with the
juniors so he was like i'm getting sent
home i'm using home oh no i've done it
again oh [ __ ] i'm just going
what's going on like
we've done something wrong like what's
going on that's so oblivious so um
get home
get back to the hotel and i'm straight
to the scratch right because i'm pretty
tired i'll see him slept after fall
asleep on my bed at 7pm the night before
and getting home at three or four
o'clock in the afternoon
on a sunday and so i had to sleep and
then we had a meeting after
um
dinner and
um i'll say they said whoever stayed up
past five o'clock or something i stayed
behind and
a few guys got told off and then tana
sort of turned to me whose tunnel
tunnel's captain the time and goes
eaton i don't even know who the [ __ ] you
are
what gives you a right
you're not even an all black you haven't
even played a game yet what gives you
the right to do that on the site
this is the biggest dressing down of my
life i'm so embarrassed i just want to
crawl and hold and die
um
but yeah that was my first week as an
author
one of the great weeks
one of the great stories
and then yeah
and saying that like um
obviously a few guys are in you know
decent trouble around it but uh
they moved on pretty quickly within camp
i guess is you know pretty smart from
them i'll see
you know deal with it not sweeping on
the carpet or anything but just move on
and
um
also i wasn't planning that first week
so
um
so it was a bit of a nice distraction to
get my head down and focus again i guess
um
yes
yeah hell of a week how old are the boys
around you um after that moment
obviously tana had a spray but was
everyone else all good yeah i guess i
guess i was a bit more sheepish than i
already was um
yeah it was interesting like um
i guess it turned into a
similar like a semi joke
to be honest like
just just
to try and move on like sort of joked
about it but um
i guess i was actually room with anton
oliver at the time
for that first week in cardiff um
so what they're doing they're all
actually new guys room with the older
guys and
you sort of learn the ways of them but
um
you know i remember
anton he was he was always busy like
doing
a bit of work on
a bit of off-field stuff with all black
site doing presentations and stuff like
that and
um
you really didn't talk to me at all that
week and i was just like okay that's
just the way it is and
it wasn't until um
ended the tour that
i think was after our last game like
walking around
so we want the grand slam and
walk around the field afterwards and
goes oh ethan you're not a bad rooster i
thought you're a bit of a dick for what
you did in cardiff
and then he goes oh that's why i didn't
talk to you all week
[Laughter]
oh that's classic but you obviously
mentioned that you won the grand slam so
on the field it was a successful
tour but what was it like for you
individually
uh you know it was
it was great um
looking back i guess
my first game was that second week
against ireland
um
and
looking back it felt really easy because
obviously i had no expectations really
on me
or for myself or anything like that and
um when i looked around the you know
obviously the guys i'm playing with are
pretty you know the best in the world
and their sort of stuff which made my
job a lot
a lot easier um
i sort of had to do do my role and
i said that's all i focused on was
getting the lineups right and make sure
i'm in the right positions and and
and the phase play and all that sort of
stuff and
um
i mean i i found actually
honestly with with no expectation i just
found it quite easy playing
within that group like it's it's because
everyone around you is so much better
and
um
going back like
no offense to the stratford boys but you
know six months earlier i was playing
with these guys carrying them
i understand that jayla
but uh
you know obviously it makes it makes a
lot easier to actually just focus on
your role and do that
so on this on side of the field it felt
really easy which i guess is
looking back is you know the naivety
i've
not played
professional rugby like at a top level
before and yeah
it was all downhill from there no java
mate i held on to that for a long time
made a career out of it
and then what was it like going from
being an all black to then coming down
to super rugby i guess down and
how did you get picked up by the
hurricanes uh yeah that was a funny
story i think we um
we're doing the all black photos before
before the tour and um obviously they
didn't like the mug shots for uh
for the uh angry teams i was like
um
which team i'm wearing like
whatever i haven't got a contract or i
mean i don't know who i'm supposed to be
playing for they're like oh you're in
the hurricane so that was the first time
when she knew who i was playing for
[ __ ] on the hurricanes jersey at this
photo shoot
um
but yeah i guess going into the
environment was strange as well like
again i didn't know anyone in there
apart from the nike boys and
and then the guys that i met on on tour
and stuff and
i guess i was an all black first which
made things a bit weird
yeah um
yeah i sort of
it wasn't like a rookie but it was a
rookie sort of weird sort of situation
um
but you know i had had a blast that
first year i mean 2006
with the hurricanes was um
it was a great year um
fog final the fog final yeah i couldn't
tell you what happened in there mate
either
no we had we had a really good season i
um again uh it was
one of those things i um
i guess it was mine i have said again
like we had a really good season and
i thought that's just how it was is just
easy like to make finals and
play well and
win lots of games and stuff and
um
it's not like that is it
unless you pay for the crusaders in
tasman
true
oh wow and and so that year was
successful for you personally on the
field you played a lot of footy you got
to the final yeah i think um
i think looking back that was probably
my best season of rugby
um i just probably played my play my
best then um number of reasons for that
probably is a couple injuries later on
yeah
um
obviously obviously i was young and
things clicked and
um you played really well i think i
played pretty much every game
um and obviously play really well with
you know within the team as well that
was playing really well and
yeah we had pretty pretty decent side
looking back and
um
obviously went through and you couldn't
quite get the um
the one in the final um
it was a bit of a weird situation that
that fog final like sort of how it
rolled in during the warm up and
um not really knew what was going on and
i still don't think anyone knows what
happened really i think casey lala
scored a try that's about it that was
the difference
yeah it was a strange one uh tough for
lineouts and kickoffs were you uh
to be honest i don't really i think
lineups wouldn't have been too bad
because you could sort of see that
that sort of
distance one memory i did have was
as i did back in my days was hanging out
the wing quite a bit or out wide
um
and i think like we're on attack but
you know the rocks on the far side of
the field and i had no idea but
apparently we've turned it over i didn't
know what but i just knew that we came
up from attack onto defense and
you know you just had an idea i think
during the game they sense
so colin cooper's coach and then ozzie
mclean was the assistant i think they
sent aussie around to the sideline just
so
he could watch that half of the field
and
the coops could see the other half if
and
whatever's happening down the middle no
one can see but
um
yeah it was so strange i guess it was
made worse because of lights too the
lights as soon as they shine on the fog
it just makes everything bright white
and
um as far as high balls and stuff no i
couldn't tell you now that's too long
ago 15 years 15 years true man that is
crazy but you mentioned you're having
probably your best year and that was
recognized globally i think you won
newcomer of the year 2006 newcomer of
the year worldwide so obviously that was
a huge achievement did you feel pressure
after winning that or how do you feel
about winning that uh
no i was pretty i mean with that award i
think it's um was voted by
the players
um which i i feel is the most you know
the highest honor to be honest it's not
some old
old rooster
you
know
i'm sure
deciding who's the best player or
anything is voted on by other players so
it was pretty uh
pretty humbling to receive that and i
think it's you know a pretty pretty good
achievement um
as far as pressure
um i i guess i remember when i received
that was sort of
on any tour in 2006.
um
and i sort of
at that stage i was sort of not quite
cementing the place in the all blacks
which i
felt um
that was probably more pressure on me
than you know living up to some award or
anything like that it was sort of more
just my
i'm probably more my my desire to be you
know nailing down the starting spot on
the all blacks and
and not quite been there at this stage
i guess i was putting more pressure on
myself than
anything else
and what was your feedback around the
all blacks especially towards the back
end when you started falling out of
favor there what was what was the comms
around that uh
well the big issue that i had was um
kickoffs actually that was
pretty much the difference between me
starting and not at that stage of my
career um
it was uh
i think it was a test in
christchurch against the aussies where
um
larkin was just putting these little
stinky little kicks straight on me and
she ended up being like 50 50 balls with
the with the guys coming through and you
know i lost quite a few of them and
i think i actually remember i think tony
woodcock had had sore thumb so he wasn't
really lifting too much and
but it was on me though like you know 50
50 i should you know i should have
backed myself to get it and
i didn't so i think that was that was
one of the big things for me
or you know i knew what i had to work on
was mainly my kickoff sales the one
thing that was really leading me down
between
starting and not
so i put a lot of work into it
um funny thing was though when i moved
to france
i did zero work on kickoffs and just
swallowed anything that came to me when
and when i put like hours and hours of
work into it
i couldn't catch a cold
maybe something on that kids i don't
know
that is
not sure about that advice but
you know
i i do think there's something in there
though like as in um
when you overthink something or put too
much pressure on something
um
you know you're over complicated and you
don't execute as well because you're
worried about the outcome like then the
process whereas
it's a bit like golf you know like
you know when you're hitting the ball
well you're probably not thinking about
you know
your liftoff of your club or whatever it
is that you're thinking about that day
you just
see bull hit ball sort of thing or you
know rugby you you know you see the spot
to jump and catch a kick off you get
there you jump and catch it yeah not
really thinking about the outcome or
i take that back that's great advice
yeah
anyway your hurricanes
i want to talk about your hurricane's
career a little bit um living i know
your flatting situation was one of the
greats you had some absolute lads and
you're flat at the time ben may richard
bachmann bowdoin bearer and james
broadhurst was that yeah james brought
his the first year in 2012 and then he
moved out with his lovely
partner brooke and then ben may moved in
in his spot
so it was 2012 2013 season
um
in my last two years with the canes so
yeah it was um good times yeah we got a
lot of mischief um
you know for like-minded individuals um
yeah we're not playing golf like twice a
week and a lot of competition between us
and
um
you know it's pretty special to have
that sort of
flat life but you know you're living
with your workmates and
um i'll see you you're not really
well i can look back to my student days
where
obviously you're living the student life
which is completely different but yeah
yeah you're living the lifestyle where
you're traveling around the world and
playing footy with your mates and
you know living that dream which um with
some special times no doubt and you were
known for sort of drinking during season
like after games every i'd imagine you
drank most after most games
yeah that was fair to say i um
i sort of made it a point to have at
least a beer after every game yeah um
there were odd occasions where i'd have
like one or two and that would be about
it
um they were very rare i'll tell you
that now
um
i'd have to be bloody injured or
something something special going on for
that happened but um
no i was
sort of just the way i um
you know i learned to play my footy uh
especially going back to um
the field in yellowstays um
you know it's very social sort of side
of things playing club rugby and
you know we had a good great group of
mates that
started out together in the senior site
at fielding and
um
you know we we'd always
train on thursday we'll go to the local
pub and fielding before we traveled we
all lived in
palmy so we'd all
go local pub there was a sponsor and
field and then go over to the army and
shower up have a bit of a feed and then
we'll meet up at the pub as well
afterwards and have a night out and
um same again on saturday play the game
and
play hard and then
it was a bit of a reward and that's what
i treated treated it like um throughout
my career like if you played
train hard all week and played well
sorted it out and
you earned yourself a beer and it was my
favorite part of the week just to
you've done the work and you able to
relax and unwind and
um you know sitting around in the change
room having to be with your mates is
is i you can't replace that was probably
the thing i miss the most about not
playing anymore um
you know you
it's like going to war it's the closest
thing i guess to going to war and you
know you can share those stories and
things you've done with your mates on
the field and having a beer is um
you know that's i think so it's not a
bad thing um
you might have a different story now
that you're
you're a coach now and
i know it seems like every player that
turns into a coach
sort of hates people that drink
you know the biggest drinkers in the
team
what were you like as a coach
still was sending it
i was probably leading the charge
i guess um
towards the end of towards the end of my
career in france i think
they used to bring out the chili bin
full of beers and swim in the middle of
the change room
and i think there's a group of us mainly
the foreigners there's a few frenchies
as well but um we made a point of it to
not leave the change room until we
finish all the beer
you know and then at some stage there
was like the security guards were coming
and going we've locked the stadium
we're still sitting there and they're
planning kirsten yeah still having it
got to the bottom of the chilly button
and they're like well where are you guys
can you hurry up
like we've kicked everyone out of the
stadium i was like oh mate we got a job
to do
it's classy was it ever midweekers for
you throughout your career uh yeah they
probably was looking back you know it
was a few times um
so
2007 through to
11. i was living with uh andrew keithel
yeah um
who hates a beer
uh we uh towards the end like last
couple of years with the deals with the
hurricanes we used to um
at tuesday we sort of was every
wednesday was a day off uh of a normal
you know said a week game
um so tuesday night we we took it as an
opportunity to get away from town and
away from rugby and
um we used to drive over to the back of
mudenborough to go um shoot theirs and
um and have quite a few beers
and just get away from things and
a bit of a
we treated like a
i'll see bit of a little let off a bit
of steam and
the pressure and stuff and
now we could be ourselves over there and
no one's gonna
judge us for being us and
um obviously there was times where we
probably took it a bit too fast drinking
and stuff but um
now we always turned up back in
wellington on wednesday and if we had
too many we would do a little session
extra session to sort it out and
get back and train and i thought that's
just what we did back then that was sort
of the
the program we had um
yeah i wouldn't recommend it for
everyone
did you feel that important for you to
have to get away because you were such a
recognizable um person
uh yeah i i feel as obviously in new
zealand as a regular player you do live
in a fish bowl
um
and it is nice if as a rugby player you
can actually
have somewhere to go
where you know you can just be yourself
um i'm not saying you can go there and
be crazy and do all sorts of things it's
just you know be surrounded by
guys people that you trust and you know
good friends and stuff and
you can actually just unwind you don't
have to put up a front or
you know be polite to some random person
or anything like that and
um you know it's nice to actually have
that ability to
or their opportunity to get away and
actually do that um
uh yeah you don't have to be doing it
every week though
so how did it all end for you i know
hammer came in and was was you're
drinking a part of
why you left
no no i think um maybe andrew keith or
yeah i think that might have had to do
with him leaving um
i think i got lumped into that with
being his right-hand man obviously
you know i was tasked with the same
brush there for a while but um
yeah i'm saying that i mean looking back
you know hammered
mark tried um changing the culture of
the hurricanes which you know looking
back needed to be done
um
you know and and his his thoughts was he
couldn't do that whilst
two big
um
two big players and personalities were
at in the club with andrew and uh ma
um
but obviously the way that it went down
so they didn't really sit well with a
lot of the guys and
the public and
that sort of stuff but um you know
looking back at the culture probably did
need to change
um
you know i came back the next year in
2012
um
and
obviously i mean i spoke to mark a lot
about that's in between seasons
obviously coming back and
um
i think
i'm not too sure we would set it allowed
but it was sort of a chance for me to
you know what slight clean and
start anew and
you know it's after that
2011 world cup we had a massive
preseason for the hurricanes and
it was like a it was like a whole new
different team that year and
um you know i got my head i stuck my
head down and worked pretty hard that
pre-season and
um
had probably one of my favorite years
actually in hurricanes
um
on a whole
um it's probably yeah it probably was
the
most enjoyable season
obviously because of the stuff we'd been
through and
sort of the new culture was sort of
building towards and
um
felt like i played actually quite a big
part in that
um moving forward and then obviously you
said i was living with these other guys
um
so now i really enjoyed that year and um
we moved forward but then towards the
end i guess 20
well actually in 2012 i um
there's a bit of a politics game that i
was playing i sort of spoke with hammett
about um
obviously he was keen to give me a rest
at some point during the season i was
like
well i don't want to give anyone else to
go so
i said oh if you want to give me a rest
just let me you know have a training or
two off like
and basically said that
i'm not much of a bench player i'm not
very good off the bench so if i'm you
know if we're going to play i should be
starting and stuff and sort of convince
them of that
um
which came back to bite me on the arse
the next year
because um by that stage we had like
threshed
obviously um worked out that he's pretty
good player and worked hard and
came good and same with broadhurst you
know he is sort of starting to click
that is a big big bugger and
quite powerful athlete and
started playing some really good code
there and so 2013
these guys are playing really well and i
was
also just plateauing really i wasn't
quite what i used to be and
what i was doing for the team wasn't
enough for me to start so then
obviously from the year before he goes
well if you're not starting you're not
in the 2022 so
just like it phased out basically and
then um
yeah they'll teach you for playing
politics um but yeah you know i guess by
the end of the years you know the
writings on the wall like obviously not
the athlete i used to be and i was
playing as well as i was so i
had to start looking for
you know wherever the next job would
come from really so that's why i started
looking overseas and japan came calling
yeah japan japan came calling um yes i
think how i ended up there was isaac
ross was over there and he just kept his
hip
um pretty badly they thought he would
never play again sorry i see he's johnny
just retired not so long ago so he's
done well from then but so i came over
his injury cover for him and
played one season over there
um
absolutely loved living in japan
the rugby side of things i didn't enjoy
as much as sort of
for me i was like if i'm training i want
to be playing
whereas over there they obviously got
the foreigner rule around
two finals in the field at a time and
i'll see that sort of bit hard being a
lock
they don't really need locks to win
games um in japan
you know they want you want big loose
forwards to run through teams and yeah
cut little japanese men in half and
always already doing that they don't
need me to
when they line up or they're pretty good
at that so um
yeah so the rugby sort of things i mean
i enjoyed it but you know for me if i'm
training hard i want to be playing so
um
didn't really work out and
i don't really get many opportunities to
play a lot so
um
you know i spent seven months over there
and then came back to new zealand and
the big search started again for for
next job and this time lara shall came
calling
yeah that took a while um
i think in this and i was back for about
four months before i actually signed for
them that's true
um i think i had a an offer to play for
the sharks and the super rugby
which i turned down
um and then i think i had an offer from
taranaki to
play lc item cup um
which i wasn't really that keen on
because you know i felt like a step back
but then lara shell came out of nowhere
and
they're playing um
signivision over there in france and
looking to try and win promotion and
they said it's like one promotion that
came for me to come over and
then they came up with a contract once
they got promoted and you know it was
two years and i was like sweet i'll take
it like
um
it was pretty easy decision at that
stage to
to to go where the work has only really
been offered i didn't really have too
many other offers so you know i felt
the stage almost been about 31
um i still felt like i had a few more a
few more good years than me and
obviously wanted to
make the most of the career while i
could and you definitely had a few more
good years left and you you ended up
playing 72 games over there 64. well i'm
sure it's more than that wasn't it oh
this is what wikipedia is telling me 64
is captain is that right
oh that sounds about right
i think that's about 92 i thought oh
true 92 games yeah i was short of the
time mate i was gutted about that oh
heartbreak but you and all seriousness
though you were a lara shell legend over
there like you the fans loved you like i
said 64 games as captain matt you were
and lara shall hero so how did you find
it over there uh i loved playing in
france obviously every club in france is
a bit different but um in lara show i
found a really good fit
for me
in terms of obviously the level of rugby
was
still very competitive
hard challenging
um
and obviously that stage of my career
like laura sheldon trained too hard
um so you know like i get through the
week's okay
um obviously living in france is pretty
pretty special
um you know there's a good balance
between obviously the social side of
things and and the rugby and
um and then the city was amazing um la
rochelle like
i liken it to
you know new plymouth as in town like
it's a
you know it's a port town
um
there's about 80 000 permanent residents
there and a lot more history than i've
seen new plymouth um
and uh very very supportive um
locals as well like uh i think they set
some record
like selling out the stadium like 50
something games in a row and it's crazy
you know like these 13 000 season ticket
holders out of 16 000 seats stadium so
um and a waiting list and that sort of
stuff so like they're very passionate
supporters but i found they're really
really supportive when i first turned up
i also was obviously new to the top top
um
top 14.
um
and was struggling there for most of
that first season but they were very
like
supportive
very different from new zealand
supporters like um
a lot more positive
support um you know there's not much of
the tool poppy over there
um
well that's what i found you know it was
my experience
um you know i really enjoyed it so much
that um i think it was within
maybe four or five months of being there
they sort of obviously were struggling
we were in the relegation zone and
they're like i had an outpost on my
contract if we got relegated and they're
like well i want you to stay
even if we go down i'll say it's fine
like um
i'm can obviously rededication a
different contract but
i sort of made a decision there like
this this is where i want to retire
um so when i'm not
wanting to play or not wanted to play
anymore you know this this is where i
was going to finish up so
it was pretty easy decision to extend
the contract and
keep going for
i guess four seasons in the end
so how's that club turned it around
because like you said they were div too
when you sort of went over and now
they're probably the or they are the
second best side in in europe now so
they've had a massive turnaround how's
that happen uh
well i guess it's a number of things um
i guess
the best thing i've found that i've done
is i've built slowly to this point
now even a couple years before i was
there they sort of
um
you know recruited smartly and
within terms of players and building up
you know like the stadium i've changed
the stadium
slowly and built a whole new training
base and
and obviously got a lot of good support
around the city
um
and obviously a lot of a lot of good
factors i mean obviously i don't know
what's happened exactly
in terms of everything behind the scenes
but um the slightly built up
um you know good good
player base and good coaching and
um
yeah like the one season we did really
well when i was here was
i don't you know what happened in terms
of playing
um it's just one of those french things
that um like we absolutely had no game
plan
this is a scary thing like um
i remember talking to conrad conrad
smith who was at power at the time and i
think he was injured at the stage but
he's done a lot of defense work for poe
and obviously and not analyzing now or
attack
and we caught up with them before the
game then uh victor and
then she said cheeky of him he goes
i've studied like your last games
what is your game plan i can't work it
out i said you work it out you tell us
but we've got no idea
but this is one of these weird french
things where
you know one of these guys we won a game
away
and then they're like oh oh we can
actually do this we can win games
and then now things click then we end up
winning like 15 or 16 games in a row and
um
and just really clicked and from then
like
yes
from there we picked it up a couple
years later and and since then i've been
you know second
obviously last year in both competitions
and
i'll see before so they've actually
backed it up and so it's actually
appealing for guys
to actually go to the club and
also the best one of the best things is
one of the better places in france i
feel that
to live and play rugby
um
i mean these other places over there
really big crappy teams but they're not
the best cities to be or
um
you know a bit biased there but
um
there's a few places i wouldn't really
want to live and play over in france
so when you mention about having no game
plan is that so how's your sort of
training week is that just
all around playing unstructured touch or
games or things like that or what are
you spending your time on you pretty
much summed it up right there gemma um
we pretty much played
15 on 15
like touch
like sort of
like throw the ball and then um
one of the biggest ones we did because
we did the same trainings week in week
out for like four years that's what
probably made me retire
but um
it was i remember the most famous one
was to be you know like the team on
attack would have well both teams would
have
bibs on but then like this player could
break the line and offload and this one
had to set a rack and
like but it's just 5915 playing touch
basically
um we'll see a few starter plays and
stuff but
i guess it had nothing to do with the
training it's just sort of
you know one of those games you know an
offload stuck and
confidence confidence is a
massive thing in sports so when you've
got it take advantage mate that's a
little bit like what you touched on a
little bit earlier around
overthinking it sometimes and just
the more the more you think about it the
worse you get so that's just taking it
right back to
what you know way just playing touch
playing rugby and just going out there
and expressing yourself it's pretty cool
you know i always come back to like the
line-outs and stuff and
a lot of
teams and players trying to
over-complicate it to win the ball yeah
it's just like rugby is a simple sport
like
you don't over complicate it just do the
basics really well and if you do that
half the job's done you're going to be a
great coach when you decide to
yeah i might just give those those guys
a listen though
you've got ticks on these days
you text them in a meeting instead of
standing up in front of them and
shouting at them as long as it's in
emojis
but you have to you have to get like a
google translate or something for them
though so you know what you're actually
sending
oh classic stuff anyway mate [ __ ] that
is one hell of a career but as always
we've gone to our instagram for some
questions anyway first question
best mullet in the game oh best mullet
in the game oh there's too many to
choose from today uh these days um
well i'll go back to like some boys back
in the day he didn't bloody outstanding
one
but in this day and age
i tell you what i think uh manga richie
monger looks a lot like bloody uh old um
lana richie he does right he's got that
look about him he sure does yeah i can
see that it's quite a puffy mullet isn't
it like quite thick out the back it is
very puffy like but a bit of a afroy
type sort of texture um but no i'd if i
had to pick someone
i don't know nah i'll go back to tim
boyce he had a proper southland dirty
mullet yeah he was good stuff okay
this was a very popular question in a
moment that i'm pretty keen to hear
about talk me through the brent ward bum
poke
yeah
uh that video hey that's following me
around the world it still does like
like any new crowd i go into where
they're like oh see oh jason you know
you just play rugby so i try and work
out who i am they might google it and
the first thing pops up is a bloody
video
um
yeah wow i guess this is one of those
spirits at the moment thinks that
i saw an opportunity just to
say get out of the old mate um
lo and behold
i i didn't realize at the time which is
pretty
very stupid to me that i'm playing rugby
and you know live television that
there's a camera right in front of me
and apparently i've looked straight out
and it's gone
but uh
yo as you ran into brentwood it must
have been last about a year ago actually
and i said my
this bloody video he goes the i know
so oh yeah so i regret that but um
obviously
yeah it was all tongue-in-cheek um no
malice involved um so i think it's been
obviously received by everyone in the
rights
the right tone so
yeah i think we should move on
that is so good
oh so good okay
um
i couldn't i didn't realize how popular
you were with the men so i've got a few
questions about your looks but this one
did you know that men question their
sexuality while watching you play
well that's first to me i don't think
i've ever been hit on
by another male um
you know i don't so that's a surprise to
me
um i'll take it oh thank you it's good
to know is that
is this little current is it
still current right still got it mate
still got it that might have been in the
club scene
is that probably because of the last
question a
yeah
yeah it might be related
whoops
okay next one favorite court session
geez you would've had a few of these
oh
yeah i've had a few
had to run a couple too that's that's
some pressure
um
favorite one
geez i remember my first one for the
felt and yellows i was so nervous so
because i've never heard anything about
it
um
favorite one
i'd probably have to go
actually
probably my most recent one actually was
um
with the obu
fighting billy goats senior reserve team
after winning
player for fifth place
last year
that was one of my funnest ones i did
enjoy that i was always been absolutely
idiot but oh i could imagine
yeah that was probably one of the
funnest ones
no that's what you want that's what you
want bit of bit of fun it's all fun and
games at the end of the day isn't it
i've had a lot of ones that have ended
ended a lot of spewing and stuff though
obviously different ones yeah the more
intense ones
it would have been a few of those in the
neck you'd imagine yeah nicki i had an
absolute shock of my ones for the nike
or your initiation wasn't it absolute
shocker
my initiation once this is the old uh
2005 ted i do have two goes at it
actually the first one the doc pulled me
so what was it six beers no it took 12
it was 12. a can every five minutes
that's right so yeah uh 12 in an hour
um i think my first first crack at it i
did seven and i think at this stage i
don't know what it was but
i felt
just after playing like my body wasn't
ready to receive so much volume and i
just needed to get it out and carry on
um but i went through a phase there
where
um
when i vomited i actually like scratched
the esophagus or something like that
some weird term some doctor they might
know more about it than me but
um but when i vomited like it just
turned my vomit like a dark
like almost perfectly like
i'll see a lot of blood in it and then
obviously doing this court session in
front of the
team management and the whole team and
the docs docs just going
no you're out
you're an idiot like stop drinking mate
i was like oh okay yeah sweet so then
you know two weeks later next court
session had to go have another go and
same thing happened but after three
beers
and then i was just like no i'm good to
go now and i'll sweet that's true
you don't make a habit of it
did was at the end of it did that
follow you for the rest of your career
or not really no i i don't think i i
think it was about
yeah 2005 for some reason that was sort
of the thing i did when i had court
sessions i think the first time i did it
was actually stratford
i think we did a um
the buggers here i think aaron moore and
she stitched about that one he um
made me do initiation for being captain
for that year
um i think i did a twist off which is
six cans
or six bottles where you do six minutes
for the first one five minutes or the
second down to one minute oh yeah and
then yeah i think that's the first time
i did it and i was freaked out eh but um
i think only happened on the three
occasions those those three occasions
but never happened again so it's quite
scary
big that purple blood oh good stuff
yeah so uh you're not you're not doing a
proper cordial unless it happens though
you would know the cordy guru next
question is also on the drinking themes
uh want to know the story around your
hundred pints
oh
hundred points ah yes no so um
which here was this 2010 i uh
i busted my right knee
playing against the
lions
in wellington and then i think the
hurricanes left on the next day for um
or might should be in the monday
actually the sunday i got the
obviously mri said you know your knees
busted so monday the hurricane's left
for three weeks for south africa
so i took it upon myself to spend three
weeks at molly malone's um trying to do
the hungry points of guinness in three
weeks
um
so i got through to
at the time i thought it was 97
in three weeks and then uh
actually i think the the day that
the hurricanes boys flew backwards i was
at the um
at a
black caps australia test match on day
four or something and end up at molly
loans and end up with um
commentators and a few yeah other people
from the cricket um
but anyway the hurricanes boys come in
and you know come straight from the
airport and come say yay and have
covered drinks and
i'll see uh
when the hurricanes tour with a uh
it's actually a kookaburra bubble bath
which is actually hamish richard
wilson's uh
a bet than andrew keith hall stole from
him and
donated to the hurricanes but so he's
the tool with that but he had that and
his belongings and then um
somehow andrew convinced merv hughes to
follow a
imaginary
delivery
so there we are modern lions and horror
takes guard
nerf hughes trots out to the um
you know courtney place out there and
stops traffic
then runs in
about to bowl the ball and then hori
pulls away goes no there's someone
behind you like
sends back the great nerf hughes with a
mentoring ball to bowl in the second one
and then his shoulders arms
on the second delivery
but anyway that's
a long story in it sorry uh
but uh 97 pints after three weeks and
then i think um
i think i had surgery and then i think a
little bit later on i came into town for
another lion brown function with my
mates and
i think on the sunday i said oh let's go
do my final three pints
um
so i went into a few of my mates and got
to the you know the third one the 100th
point and made a big spiel and
chopped it
and then uh so yeah i've done it and
then the lady behind the bars like oh
actually that's your 100 in the first
point um
[Laughter]
oh jeez hundred points that is a good
effort yeah i sort of had a limit i
could only do 14 in a session hey 14
points in a day
sure and then you'd go
now i have to have two days off though
still hell that's a lot of points
okay next question
is it true you and hori almost started a
bar
that is 100
true we
got to the point
uh must be about
we did try and get it up and running for
the 2011 world cup i think we're a bit
weren't quite ready for that um we did
put an offer in on a building here in
wellington
um
on the proviso that we could call it um
after our surname so it's going to be
called eaton halls
which we thought would be a great idea
and um no we we with business plan and
everything all set up and
um some good friends here we're gonna um
obviously help us like on the actual
running of the bar side of things and
you know what you look that close to you
know putting an offer on a lease on a
building and
it fell through so um
but uh we actually
one of our old colleagues from taranaki
back in the day sam young actually
called one to the he's like mate i want
to get involved
oh something called ethan young horse
but so yeah
there was a dream dream of house but it
didn't quite happen i think we might
have uh drank it drier though if um
so it's not something you'd look to do
still
uh
oh well i'll probably look at it but
maybe not quite calling it that we might
buy it somewhere else that we don't live
in
um we always buy it like somewhere in
like christchurch or something it's sort
of halfway between where we live yeah
meet up have a little catch up every now
and again yeah that's the one where i
see a lot you're right you will be drunk
dry okay last question
best piece of advice you received
throughout your career
jeepers
um
uh this is a piece of advice that i
received i don't know i don't know
whether there is
one
best piece i guess if i was to give
anyone some advice it would be
um
obviously have a good balance between
everything like um
obviously if you turn up to train you've
got to have everything in an order on
the home front and
um not worrying about one thing while
you're doing the other so
obviously you make sure you're
everything
in order and i think you do that through
through having a good work life balance
um
you know and don't take everything so
seriously either like
um
you know
you have that opportunities to switch
off like we we spoke about at the start
of the podcast like yesterday's yeah if
you play with your close mates and
unwind take those opportunities because
you know that the
goal when you when you're
in the pressure situation of
you know especially new zealand rugby so
obviously
so that the main
takeaway from that's you know have a
good balance between
off field and on field sort of
life make sure everyone's
happy
oh how good and nobody did it better
than yourself you were the master at it
depends who you ask mate some people
would say i'd leant one way too much
mate but you had a hell of a time doing
it and mate absolute pleasure having you
on the podcast mate there's some unreal
stories in there from one of the great
careers and one of the great lads
obviously love my time playing with you
up in the nike and briefly at the keynes
and matt you're an absolute legend so it
was a pleasure talking to you and
getting the run down on your whole
journey
thanks gentlemen mate keep up the good
work mate you're on to a winner here
cheers mate i appreciate it especially
getting yarns like yours on
yeah sure i don't know whether they're
um
well are they user friendly i don't know
no
we'll we'll soon find out i might get a
few questions from like um like carter
or something going mate what are you
freaking telling the actual story and
well he can always come on and sit it
straight yeah
there you go mate i've set it up for you
okay i've messaged him he said no so
that's all right i did it
too big too big
too big yeah
now i feel i appreciate it though mate
absolute pleasure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you